a major easter egg has been revealed
that has to do with phase four of the
MCU and the future of the MCU in general
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this Easter egg was just recently
revealed in spider-man far from home and
if you are worried about spoilers don't
be I'm not going to spoil anything about
the movie in this video as i mentioned
this huge easter egg has to do with the
future of the MCU but more specifically
it has to do with the future of the MCU
in the cosmos we already know that the
MCU moving forward is going to be
divided into two one is going to be a
grounded MCU which will take place on
earth and another is a cosmic MC which
will take place all over space and this
Easter Egg could be a key to introducing
the x-men as well I'll break it all down
in this video but real quick if you
would like a chance to win a Captain
America shield an Iron Man helmet and
Infinity Gauntlet or another Marvel
Legends item be sure to subscribe to my
channel I'm picking three winners at the
450,000 subscriber mark so this Easter
Egg is in the spider-man far from home
post credits scene again I will not give
anything away about the movie and I will
only be talking about one specific part
in the post credits scene at the end of
the post credits scene we see a certain
character on a ship in space the ship
appears to be in deep space and on this
ship we can see that there are scroll so
what is this mysterious headquarters
that's in deep space well this appears
to be a sword base for those of you who
are not aware of what sword is sword
stands for sentient world observation
and response department sword is a
counterterrorism and intelligence agency
whose purpose is to deal with
extraterrestrial threats to the world
and it is a counterpart to you guessed
it shield and guess who is in charge of
it for some time in the comics that's
right Nick Fury since the future of the
MCU is said to be exploring the cosmos
it would make sense that sword would be
set up especially after the end of
Captain Marvel when Carol Danvers goes
into deep space with Talos and the rest
of his people theory would then know
obviously that there are threats that
could come from outer space that was the
whole point of the Avengers initiative
to have a group of people who could deal
with extraterrestrial threats but you
can bet that Nick Fury would have
something in place that would prevent
extraterrestrial threats from even
getting to the earth and that's when
sword comes in
to play and especially after avengers
endgame where it Captain Marvel rocket
and nebula were in charge of monitoring
space for threats so it really lines up
that sword is already developed in the
MCU which would mean the space facility
that we see at the end of the
post-credits scene for spider-man 5 from
home is most likely the peak the peak is
the headquarters for sword which would
make sense as to why that certain
character was there in the post-credits
scene for spider-man far from home so
Nick Fury is originally in charge of
sword but when he leaves
Abigail bran becomes in charge and
Abigail brand is a mutant who has
pyrokinetic powers so if sword is going
to be a big part of the MCU cosmic
future they could introduce Abigail
brand which would introduce the x-men
sword was actually introduced for the
very first time in the astonishing x-men
so sword has some major connections to
the x-men and mutants so with the
introduction of sword into the MCU not
only could it play a huge role for
characters like Captain Marvel Nova the
guardians of galaxy but it could also
play a huge part in introducing the
x-men and the Fantastic Four into the
MCU San Diego comic-con is right around
the corner in which we will hopefully
learn a lot more about phase 4 and the
future of the MCU so be sure to comment
with your thoughts on this sword Easter
egg and the post-credits scene for
Spider Man far from home also don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
the giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fluff